I’m sure when you think “biggest television
events” around, you think of the 1 billion
people who watched India vs Pakistan in the
2015 Cricket World Cup… right?
No.
No, I can’t say that I do.
Oh.
Uh, the Moon Landing at 530 million, worldwide?
No, I think of the biggest television event
everrrr, the BIG GAME!!!!!!!!!
A piddly 115 million!
Hey there sportsfaaaans, Trace and Emily here
for DNews to talk about sportsball and science.
You probably know, today is Superb Owl. number
El-Eye.
American Football’s greatest event.
And with all those people in one place, you
bet your deflated Brady-Ball there’s a ton
of science going on.
Stadiums are one of the few times a large
number of people gather to a controlled place,
so while most of them are focused on the field,
we can use this rare mass gathering to do
some cool studies.
For example, on January 8, 2011, earthquake
monitoring equipment registered something
strange in the Seattle area -- a tiny earthquake.
(Seriously, really tiny).
According to researchers at the Pacific Northwest
Seismic Network, eight Seattle Seahawks football
games register on their nearby seismometer
during their study -- it’s across the street
from the stadium.
Their short write-up, published in Seismological
Research Letters details how they spotted
it.
The equipment was so sensitive, a write up
on the PNSN’s website said, that they of
course, could detect the rumbling of all the
fans, but they could also detect cars coming
and going, and use the data to tell if the
team was losing.
After a few losses, the “less raucous”
crowd rumbled a lot less.
Though, in 2013, the researchers registered
a 1-to-2 magnitude rumble emanating from the
stadium.
The team was on the rebound!
This wasn’t the first time sports caused
a little rumble.
At Louisiana State, there was a 15-20 minute-long
seismometer trigger in 1988 -- it was widely
reported in the media, and has become known
as “the earthquake game.”
And these two stadiums have a couple things
in common, they hold a lot of people--
LSU had 79,431
And the Seahawks had 68,387
An average of about 74 thousand humans.
Right!
So, back to the Superb Owl -- using marketing
stats on who watches the big game, we can
estimate the average weight of say -- 74,000
fans… (a little more than the Houston stadium
where El-Eye is going down).
… at least 13.5 million pounds of human
(6.1M kg).
Jumping up and down.
Maybe more!
Seismographs can actually detect incredibly
small movements in the Earth.
These human “quakes,” while fun for the
media to report on, weren’t actual earthquakes,
because they weren’t inside the Earth’s
crust -- they only imparted force onto the
crust.
The thing is, people aren’t just jumping,
they’re also shouting and breathing and
talking.
That’s a lot of people air moving in and
out.
On average, we breathe a little over 2 cups
of air at a time (500mL), this is called the
tidal volume.
Meaning, in a stadium, with 74,000 people
they’re collectively sucking in 9,774 gallons
(37,000L) of air at any given moment!
That’s 105 pounds pounds of air (47.5kg)!
Just from breathing normally!
Technically, a bit less because, fun fact,
humid air weighs less than dry air.
Actually, riffing on that.
Human breath is hot--
Yes, about 94 degrees
and completely saturated with water
Yes, it’s 100-percent humidity in there.
So, the exhalation of 37,000 liters of hot,
humid air would contain about 1.5 liters of
water!
GROSS.
Human water.
In fact, an informal study done at Louisiana
State University compared readings inside
and outside their stadium during a game and
found humidity spikes from all those breathing
meatbags.
But look, this is the Superb Owl.
If they’re in that stadium, they’re probably
also shouting.
The current Guinness Record-holder for loudest
stadium is the Kansas City Chiefs.
In September 2014, they shouted at 142.2 decibels
-- louder than a jet flying over.
And while a lot of people argue over who’s
louder...
It’s not actually a great measure of power.
The further from the sound you get, the lower
the relative intensity.
For example, a person on the opposite end
of the football field from someone hearing
a 142 decibel reading would only hear 113
decibels.
One, is a jet taking off and the other is
just a regular old rock concert.
In the end, masses of humanity can do something
to affect the world around us.
If we stick together.
Or just… breathe a lot.
Yuck.
No matter the American sport, we gotta have
a ref, ump, or someone who gets all uppity
and is usually wrong.
Are all refs just bad?
Or what?
Find out here.
Who you rooting for in the Superb Owl?
Barn?
Screech?
Northern white-faced?
Southern white-faced?
Hedwig?
Tell us in the comments.
That “superb owl” thing just kills me.
And thanks for watching DNews.